Imaginen galletas
cálidas y crocantes,
caramelos crujientes,
tortas aterciopeladas,
conos de waffles apilados
con helado.
¿Se les hace agua la boca?
¿Desean un postre?
¿Por qué?
¿Qué ocurre en el cerebro
que hace de los alimentos azucarados
algo difícil de resistir?
Azúcar es un término general
que se usa para describir
una clase de moléculas
llamadas hidratos de carbono
y se encuentra en una amplia
variedad de comidas y bebidas.
Miren las etiquetas de los
productos dulces que compran.
Glucosa,
fructosa,
sacarosa,
maltosa,
lactosa,
dextrosa,
y almidón
todas son formas de azúcar.
Son de alta fructosa el jarabe de maíz,
los jugos de fruta,
el azúcar en crudo
y la miel.
Y el azúcar no solo está
en dulces y postres,
también se añade
a la salsa de tomate,
al yogurt,
a la fruta disecada,
a las aguas saborizadas,
o las barras de granola.
Como el azúcar está por doquier,
es importante entender
cómo afecta al cerebro.
¿Qué ocurre cuando
el azúcar toca la lengua?
Comer un poco de azúcar,
¿les hace desear más?
Comen un bocado de cereal.
Los azúcares que contiene
activan los receptores de lo dulce,
parte de las papilas
gustativas de la lengua.
Estos receptores envían una señal
al tronco cerebral,
y, desde allí, se bifurca
en muchas áreas del cerebro anterior,
uno de las cuales
es la corteza cerebral.
Diferentes secciones
de la corteza cerebral
procesan diferentes gustos:
amargo,
salado,
umami,
y, en nuestro caso, dulce.
A, partir de aquí,
la señal activa
el sistema de recompensa
del cerebro.
Este sistema de recompensas
es una serie
de vías eléctricas y químicas
que surcan varias regiones
diferentes del cerebro.
Es una red complicada,
pero ayuda a responder una sola
pregunta subconsciente:
¿Debería comer otra vez?
Esa sensación cálida,
difusa, que uno siente
al probar la torta de
chocolate de la abuela.
Es el sistema de recompensas que dice:
"Mmm, ¡sí!"
Y no se activa solamente con la comida.
La socialización,
el comportamiento sexual
y las drogas
son solo algunos ejemplos
de cosas y experiencias
que también activan
el sistema de recompensas.
Pero sobreactivar este
sistema de recompensas
dispara una serie de
eventos desafortunados:
pérdida de control,
deseo,
y aumento de la tolerancia al azúcar.
Volvamos al bocado de cereal.
Viaja hasta el estómago
y, finalmente, al intestino.
Y adivinen qué.
Allí también hay receptores de azúcar.
No hay papilas gustativas,
pero sí se envían señales
que le indican al cerebro
que uno está lleno
o que el cuerpo debería
producir más insulina
para contrarrestar el azúcar extra
que estamos comiendo.
La divisa principal
de nuestro sistema de recompensa
es la dopamina,
un químico o neurotransmisor importante.
Hay muchos receptores de dopamina
en el cerebro anterior,
pero no están distribuidos
de manera uniforme.
Algunas áreas tienen
densos grupos de receptores
y estas zonas activas de dopamina
son parte del sistema de recompensa.
Drogas como el alcohol,
la nicotina,
o la heroína
envían dopamina a toda marcha,
y llevan a algunas personas
a buscar constantemente ese estímulo,
en otras palabras, a ser adictas.
El azúcar también provoca
liberación de dopamina,
aunque no de forma
tan violenta como las drogas.
El azúcar es raro entre los
alimentos que inducen la dopamina.
El brócoli, por ejemplo,
no tiene ningún efecto
y eso quizá explique
por qué es tan difícil
que los niños coman vegetales.
Y hablando de alimentos saludables,
digamos que tienen hambre
y deciden ingerir
una comida equilibrada.
Lo hacen y eso hace subir
los niveles de dopamina
en las zonas activas
del sistema de recompensa.
Pero si comen lo mismo
muchos días seguidos,
los niveles de dopamina
subirán cada vez menos,
y finalmente se nivelarán.
Y se debe a que,
en materia de comida,
el cerebro evolucionó para
prestar especial atención
a gustos nuevos o diferentes.
¿Por qué?
Por 2 razones.
Primero, para detectar
comida en mal estado.
Y segundo, porque
cuanta más variedad
tengamos en la dieta,
es más probable que tengamos
todos los nutrientes que necesitamos.
Para mantener esa variedad,
tenemos que poder
reconocer nuevos alimentos,
y más importante aún,
tenemos que querer
seguir comiendo nuevos alimentos.
Y por eso bajan
los niveles de dopamina
cuando el alimento se vuelve aburrido.
Ahora, volvamos a la comida.
¿Qué pasa si en lugar
de un plato saludable, balanceado,
comemos alimentos ricos en azúcares?
Si uno raramente come azúcar
o no come mucha azúcar junta,
el efecto es similar al
de una comida balanceada.
Pero si uno come demasiada azúcar,
la respuesta de dopamina no se nivela.
En otras palabras,
comer mucha azúcar
seguirá siendo recompensado.
De ese modo, el azúcar
se comporta un poco como la droga.
Es una razón por la que
la gente queda enganchada
a los alimentos azucarados.
Y volviendo a los
distintos tipos de azúcar.
Cada uno es único,
pero cada vez que consumimos
cualquiera de ellos,
se activa un efecto dominó en el cerebro
que dispara un sentimiento gratificante.
Con mucha frecuencia,
las cosas pueden ir a toda marcha.
Así que, sí, el consumo
excesivo de azúcar
puede tener efectos
adictivos en el cerebro,
pero una porción de torta
de vez en cuando no hace daño.